Speaker 1: Listen, Herschel Walker has been
caught in another lie, this time by his own
mother.
By his own mother.
You might remember that one of Herschel Walker's
kids, Christian Walker, turned against him
and denounced him early last week, calling
him a liar, calling him a hypocrite.
Well, now Herschel Walker's mom is saying
that story he told about being full blooded
Cherokee, Native American.
That story absolutely isn't true.
The Daily Beast reporting Herschel Walker's
full blood Cherokee claim is news to his mom.
Let's start with the video clip.
This is from a couple of weeks ago.
Here's what Herschel Walker had to say about
his own supposed Native American ancestry.
Because I tell.
Unidentified: You, wait, wait.
I found something out.
And then on my ear, I found something out.
And on me and this I.
Speaker 4: Found something out.
My mom just told me that my mom grandmother
was full blooded Cherokee.
So I'm Native American.
I was like, Oh, hello.
So I'm.
I'm almost Superman.
I don't know what I am, but this was so funny.
This was so funny.
And I said, Mom, why you never say anything
to us?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So he found out that he's a full blooded Native
American.
Turns out his mom has no idea what he's talking
about.
There is a very good Daily Beast article here,
which let's see if I can pull up.
We have gotten a very unfortunate paywall
here all of a sudden, and I want to have this
for us so that we can see it.
His mother indicating she is not aware of
such family history.
If you check out the article, you see that
Walker's mother, Christine, spoke to Huffington
Post and said she has no idea if an immediate
ancestor was full blooded Cherokee.
She said she grew up hearing stories about
her father's mother being kin to the tribe,
clarifying that her grandmother was believed
to be related to Cherokee peoples in some
way but didn't know how.
Doesn't know how far back the Cherokee heritage
goes and has no further information.
Herschel.
Herschel Walker says I'm full blooded Cherokee.
Recall that when Elizabeth Warren had actual
stories in her family about being Native American.
This is the treatment that she got.
Speaker 5: Because, you know, we're talking
too soon.
We got a year and a half left.
It's like when I called Pocahontas.
Pocahontas.
I should have waited six months because she
then went out and got that test.
1000/24 And I've always said I have more Indian
blood in me than she has in her.
And I have none.
I have none, but is more than she has.
1020.
Speaker 1: And this went on for months with
Elizabeth Warren.
Speaker 5: But I brought it up too soon, so
I don't talk about it anymore.
But she should be the candidate, which I tend
to doubt.
But if she should be, we'll bring it up again.
And I think it'll be very successful.
1,024th.
How about this?
I was driving her crazy.
So she went out and hired a guy to check the
blood.
I'm sure he had a lot of fun doing that.
He checked her blood and found out that many,
many, many, many, many, many years ago.
There could have been somebody and he could
have been in there.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So that that persisted for months.
Now, Herschel Walker just straight up lying.
His own mother says, I have no idea what he's
talking about.
Within two weeks and silence, silence from
the very same Republicans who were saying,
oh, Elizabeth Warren did something so wrong.
Stolen privilege and all these stolen benefits
by claiming to be Native American, which,
by the way, wasn't even true.
The double standards.
You know, I don't really care who's Native
American.
I don't really care about you know, if there's
if there's a cognitive issue or a health issue,
whatever, Fetterman Walker would just be consistent.
Guys, that's all I'm asking for.
Just please be consistent.
Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We will take a very brief break and be right
back.
The David Pakman Show continues to be a program
that depends on the support of our viewer
and listener community.
We have something called the membership program.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code, big voting 22
for a discount and you will get instant access
to the daily bonus show, the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show and exclusive
members only town halls where I open the phone
lines and take questions from you from the
members sign up at join dot com.